and our legal traditions as far as this
this social norm of monogamy comes from
not really Christianity but from this
Roman tradition and that's what we are
dealing with and so when Muslims are
often arguing about how polygamy or
polygyny is haram or stuff like that
because I hear these things from people
regularly there often just they're often
dealing with social norms that came to
us from from Rome not really from our
tradition or practically any other
tradition in the world so if you take
okay from one example this being a
blessing of mercy for women you have so
many women who we gave examples divorced
widowed you know so many men are dying
in wars what do you do with all these
women you know what are you going to go
towards you know they need their needs
met also they need a partner in life
many end up leaving their Dean their
religion they go up and maybe fall into
promiscuity to fornication right right
you need to eat well and that's the
second question so once you answer what
is natural is it is it rational he's a
rationing doesn't make sense can there
be wisdom in that especially given
certain circumstances it may not be for
everyone it's it's not encouraged for
each and every single individual it may
not benefit every man it may not benefit
every woman but in many cases or at
least in certain cases it is it's very
rational it makes sense like you said
what do you do in the population is is
not one to one what's going to end up
happening is you got a bunch of people
and generally you'll have higher levels
of women populations with wars and all
of that even historically right
especially historically even if you
argue in some cases it's not it's not
the case or whatever it is nonetheless
you will have a not exact one-to-one map
distribution of male to female so what
do you do in that case the only other
option is you just leave them all
unmarried yeah and that's that's a major
problem in and of itself subscribe right
now